>> ♫ ♫
>> THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
BREAKING NEWS ROCKING
WASHINGTON, D.C.
TWO KEY SENATORS WILL VOTE YES
TO CONFIRM BRETT KAVANAUGH.
SUSAN COLLINS AND JOE MANCHIN
ANNOUNCED THEIR DECISION.
A PART OF SENATOR’S COLLINS
SPEECH ON THE SENATE FLOOR.
>> I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT THESE
CHARGES CAN FAIRLY PREVENT JUDGE
KAVANAUGH WHEN SERVING ON THE
COURT.
TO THAT LEAKER WHO I HOPE IS
LISTENING NOW, LET ME SAY THAT
WHAT YOU DID WAS UNCONSCIONABLE.
SO PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN OUR
JUDICIARY AND OUR HIGHEST COURT
IS RESTORED.
MR. PRESIDENT, I WILL VOTE TO
CONFIRM JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
>> THE FINAL VOTE IS EXPECTED
TOMORROW IN WHAT COULD BE MITCH
McCONNELL’S BIG WIN.
THE WHITE HOUSE RESPONDED WITH
THIS TWEET FROM SARAH SANDERS.
THANK YOU, SENATOR COLLINS FOR
STANDING BY YOUR CONVICTIONS AND
DOING THE RIGHT THING TO CONFIRM
JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
I THINK WE ALL WATCHED COLLINS
SPEECH.
IT WAS AN IMPORTANT SPEECH.
I WONDER WHAT YOU THOUGHT OF IT.
>> STARTED TALKING AND I
STARTED YAWNING.
I REALIZED I AM MISSING
SOMETHING HUGE.
I AM NOT TRAINED TO HEAR IT.
WE SPENT SO MUCH TIME WITH
SHORT, LOUD TRUMPIAN SPEECHES.
THIS MIGHT BE THE MOST IMPORTANT
SPEECH I HAVE HEARD IN YEARS.
SHE WAS NOT JUST DEFENDING
KAVANAUGH.
SHE WAS DEFENDING HOURLY SYSTEM
AND TRYING TO PRESERVE THE
INSTITUTION.
SHE WAS LIKE PREVIOUSLY IN THE
GOVERNMENT.
SHE WENT FROM THE BEGINNING TO
THE PRESENT TIME AND TOOK US
THROUGH THE RESISTANCE AND HIS
LEGAL BACKGROUND.
SHE WAS A HAMMER OF REASON GOING
THROUGH ALL OF THIS STUFF.
SHE BROUGHT US FROM THE START TO
THE FINISH PROVIDING COVER FOR
EVERYBODY ELSE.
SHE SPOKE NOT FOR KAVANAUGH.
SHE WAS SPEAKING FOR US.
I GO TO TWITTER BECAUSE I SEE
OTHER MEDIA MAKING JOKES ABOUT
HER.
MALE REPORTERS MOCKING HER
BECAUSE SHE IS SLOW OR BORING.
BUT THEY ARE DUMBER THAN ME FOR
DOING THAT.
THEY ARE MAKING FUN OF A WOMAN.
A BRAVE WOMAN.
SHE’LL BE HARASSED FOR THE REST
OF HER LIFE.
>> SHE DECIDED TO DO IT ON
MERITS.
THIS WAS NOT A PARTISAN DECISION
FOR HER.
>> IT SHOULD NOT BE THIS CLOSE.
THE MEDIA HAS BEEN COMPLICIT IN
SPREADING THE DISINFORMATION.
THE MEDIA IGNORED AND THE
THE LETTER FROM FORD’S BOYFRIEND
THAT RAISED CREDIBILITY ISSUES,
BOYFRIEND OF JULIE SWETNICK
RAISED QUESTIONS ABOUT HER
CREDIBILITY AND PARTICIPATING IN
UNSAFFORY THINGS THAT I CAN’T
SAY ON TELEVISION.
HER HISTORY OF FRIVOLOUS
LAWSUITS.
AND THEY BURIED THE MITCHELL
REPORT.
THE MEDIA BURIED THAT.
THEY NEVER TALKED ABOUT ALL OF
THE WITNESSES ALLEGED THAT COULD
NOT CORROBORATE THIS STORY FROM
FORD.
THERE WAS AN INTERESTING POLLING
QUESTION.
IT WAS UNDER 50% PUBLIC SUPPORT
FOR THE KAVANAUGH CONFIRMATION.
YOU WERE TOLD THAT THE ALLEGED
WITNESSES COULD NOT CORROBORATE
FORD IT SKY ROCKETS TO 60%.
STILL THINGS ARE LEAKING.
THE FRIEND OF FORD ALLEGEDLY
TRIED TO GET THEM TO CHANGE
THEIR STORY.
A FORMER FBI AGENT.
SHE WAS COACHED BY FORD ON HOW
TO TAKE A POLYGRAH TEST.
THIS WOMAN IS REPRESENTED BY A
LAWYER WHO LEFT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IN A HUFF OVER
TRUMP’S ELECTION AND OVERSAW THE
HILLARY CLINTON PROBE.
VERY SKETCHY STUFF.
GRASSLEY IS ALLUDING TO MORE
COORDINATION BETWEEN FORD’S TEAM
AND DIANNE FEINSTEIN.
SUSAN COLLINS MENTIONED THESE
THINGS.
THESE ANTICS.
THE AVANATI ACCUSATIONS DIDN’T
HELP.
EVERYTHING THAT THESE PEOPLE DO
IN THE HALLWAYS IS NOT HELPING.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK BACK AT THIS
THING AND SAY THE DEMOCRATS
OVER-PLAYED THEIR HAND HERE.
>> DID YOU THINK GIVEN ALL OF
YOUR EXPERIENCE --
>> I CAN’T BELIEVE I SAT HERE
AND LISTENED TO THAT WITHOUT
ERUPTING IN RAGE OR BEGAN TO
SHOW MY EXPLOSIVE PASSIONS.
I AM NOT JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
I DON’T GET A CHANCE TO CRY.
>> ONLY WOMEN CRY?
THAT’S VERY SEXIST TO MAKE FUN
OF A MAN FOR CRYING.
>> I NEVER MADE FUN OF ANYBODY
CRYING.
I HAVE SEEN A LOT OF MEN CRY IN
MY LIFE.
>> I DID THAT ONCE AFTER ONE
SHOW.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> IF I HAD A TISSUE I WOULD
GIVE IT TO YOU NOW.
I COULD SING AND YOU WOULD CRY.
>> UP UNTIL SUSAN COLLINS GAVE
HER SPEECH DID YOU THINK THERE
WAS A CHANCE THAT THE
REPUBLICANS MIGHT NOT GET THIS
CONFIRMATION DONE?
>> WHEN IT COMES TO SENATE
NOMINATIONS FOR JUDICIAL
POSITIONS, THE REPUBLICANS HAVE
ONLY ONE SPEED:
GO AHEAD AND GET IT DONE.
WE SAW WITH GARLAND.
HE DIDN’T GET A HEARING.
WE SAW WITH JUSTICE GORSUCH, HE
GOT A HEARING.
THEY GOT IT DONE.
THREE DEMOCRATS WALKED ACROSS
THE AISLE TO SUPPORT HIM.
LOOK, I AM NOT GOING TO SIT HERE
AND BELITTLE THE WOMEN WHO HAVE
COME FORWARD.
I WON’T TRY TO BRING BACK OLD
CONVERSATION BUSY THEIR PAST
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT APPLYING
FOR A LIFETIME POSITION ON THE
CEREMENT.
-- SUPREME COURT.
JUDGE KAVANAUGH SHOULD HAVE
EXPECTED THAT HIS LIFE HISTORY
WOULD COME UP.
WE EXPECT THAT WITH A CANDIDATE
FOR PRESIDENT -- SORRY, I
TOUCHED YOU.
>> I LIKE BEING TOUCHED.
I AM FROM AN ITALIAN FAMILY AND
WE ARE ALWAYS TOUCHING EACH
OTHER.
>> NO ONE EXPECTS TO BE ACCUSED
OF GANG RAPE.
>> OR FALSELY ACCUSED.
YOU CAN’T ANTICIPATE THAT YOU
WILL BE FALSELY ACCUSED.
>> BUT YOU CAN ANTICIPATE THAT
YOUR ENTIRE PAST WILL COME UP IN
THE MANNER OF NOT JUST HEARINGS
BUT A MANNER OF INVESTIGATIONS.
THAT BEING SAID, THIS VOTE WILL
LIKELY HAPPEN WITHIN THE NEXT 22
HOURS.
IT APPEARS THEY HAVE THE VOTES.
WE DON’T KNOW.
PEOPLE WHO ARE STILL UPSET.
PEOPLE STILL WANT TO WEIGH IN.
CALL YOUR U.S. SENATORS.
IT’S NOT OVER.
ABAN IS LOOKING INTO JUDGE
KAVANAUGH APPEARANCE LIST.
>> RIGHT BUT NOT LOOKING AT
AVANATI. IS LOOKING INTO JUDGE
KAVANAUGH APPEARANCE LIST.
>> RIGHT BUT NOT LOOKING AT
AVANATI.
>> BUT AVANATI IS NOT APPLYING
FOR A LIFETIME APPEARANCE.
>> SHOULD HE BE PRACTICING LAW?
>> WE KNOW HE HAS A GREAT
TANNING DEAL.
>> BUT YOU LOOK GREAT.
>> I USE MAKEUP AND I AM HALF
ITALIAN.
THE MOST POWERFUL SENATOR IS
SENATOR JOE MANCHIN.
HE IS NOT JUST SOMEBODY THAT
SAYS I AM PRO GUN AND
ANTI-OBAMACARE.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME HE HAS
HAD A MAJOR VOTE AS A SO-CALLED
MODERATE DEMOCRAT.
WE IS WOOABLE.
>> WHO IS
>> WHO SE
>> WHO IS WOOING HIM?
>> IF HE IS A DEMOCRAT THAT WILL
GO ACROSS THE AISLE AND VOTE.
I WOULD SAY THIS ABOUT THIS
WHOLE THING.
>> WE HAVE A CHANCE TO TALK
ABOUT JOE MANCHIN IN A MOMENT.
HOLD THAT THOUGHT.
WE’LL WILL GET TO JOHN ROBERTS.
HE HAS BREAKING NEWS ABOUT HIM.
>> THAT WAS ONE OF THE MOST
COMPREHENSIVE SPEECHES IN QUITE
SOMETIME.
THERE WERE NO BAD GUYS.
THE ONLY BAD GUY WAS THE
LEASHING.
-- LEAKER.
FEINSTEIN I KNOW YOU WOULD NOT
DO THAT.
SHE IS TRYING TO RE-START.
SHE IS TRYING TO START FRESH.
LET’S SAY THE NEXT THING IS
OPIOIDS.
SOMETHING WE CAN DO TOGETHER.
I THINK WE ARE STARING AT THE
CLIFF AND NOBODY WANTS TO JUMP.
NOT REPUBLICANS OR DEMOCRATS.
I THINK THE NEXT TIME YOU HAVE
ME BACK HERE IN 2021, WE WILL
HAVE A SITUATION WHERE PEOPLE
ARE MAKING DEALS AGAIN.
>> SPEAK OF JOE MANCHIN THE
SENATOR FROM WEST VIRGINIA.
JOHN ROBERTS IS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
I THINK YOU HAVE SOME TIDBIT
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED TODAY?
>> I DO.
FIRST TO BRIAN’S POINT, YOU
COULD LAY A SAFE BET THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN
CAMPAIGNING HEAVILY IN WEST
VIRGINIA AND MAY NOT MAKE ANY
MORE CAMPAIGN APPEARANCES THERE.
JOE MANCHIN WAS A BIG PART OF
THIS.
I TALKED TO THE WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS.
AFTER THE CLOTURE VOTE.
DO YOU THINK YOU CAN HOLD TO ON
MANCHIN?
THEY SAID YES.
THAT THIS MORNING SENATOR JOE
THE REASON FOR THAT OPTIMISM WAS
MANCHIN CALLED THE WHITE HOUSE
A YES ON THE CONFIRMATION FOR
AND SAID THAT HE WAS GOING TO BE
BRETT KAVANAUGH.
PEOPLE AROUND HERE WERE HAPPY
TODAY THINKING THIS WOULD GO
THROUGH.
THE ONE WILD CARD WAS SUSAN
COLLINS.
SHE DIDN’T CALL THE WHITE HOUSE
TO SAY SHE WOULD BE A YES.
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS ASSUMED IF
SHE WAS GOING TO BE A NO, THAT
SHE WOULD HAVE CALLED TO INFORM
THEM OF THAT.
THEY LEARNED OF HER DECISION IN
REAL TIME JUST LIKE THE REST OF
US.
THEY WERE HANGING ON EVERY WORD
SHE SAID.
SHE LAID OUT THE JUDICIAL CASE
FOR JUDGE KAVANAUGH AND PIVOTED
BACK ON THE ALLEGATIONS AND THEN
PIVOTED BACK TO THE POSITIVE.
WITH SENATOR DAINES OUT OF
MONTANA FOR HIS DAUGHTER’S
WEDDING, YOU HAVE A 50-49
MARGIN.
IF SOMETHING WERE TO HAPPEN, HE
COULD COME BACK.
IT’S A SAFE BET TO SAY THE
VICE-PRESIDENT WILL PROBABLY BE
AROUND TOWN JUST IN CASE.
>> JESSE, A QUICK QUESTION?
>> A COMMENT.
>> A FUNNY ONE?
>> [LAUGHING].
>> IT BETTER BE.
>> IF I WERE JOE MANCHIN I WOULD
HAVE HELD OUT FOR MORE.
REMEMBER OBAMACARE AND HOW THEY
GOT THROUGH.
THE CORN HUSKER KICKBACK?
WHAT DID HE GET THROUGH.
OBAMA GOT THAT THROUGH WITH
BRIBES AND LIES.
THIS WAS MAYBE LUNCH?
>> WE COULD HAVE GOTTEN MORE.
>> I THINK HE DID ACTUALLY
DEMAND A PIECE OF WEDDING CAKE
FROM SENATOR DAINES WHEN HE
COMES BACK FROM MONTANA.
THIS WOULD HAPPEN.
THIS IS NOT TO SAY ANYTHING LIKE
YOU WILL REMEMBER 2 YEARS AGO
GOVERNOR JIM JUSTICE A LIFELONG
DEMOCRAT SWITCHED TO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE SAID THEY WOULD
NOT BE SURPRISED TO SEE JOE
MANCHIN RUN AS A REPUBLICAN IN
2024.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, JOHN
ROBERTS.
DONNA, MOVE ON.ORG AND
PRIORITIES USA HAVE ANNOUNCED
THEY ARE PULLING FUNDING FROM
JOE MANCHIN WHO MIGHT NOT NEED
IT ANYMORE.
AND PULLING IT FROM PHIL
GRETTISON IN TENNESSEE IN A
TIGHT RACE AGAINST MARSHA BLACK
TIGHT RACE AGAINST MARSHA
BLACKBURN.
>> PHIL STILL HAS A SHOT TO WIN
THE U.S. SENATE RACE.
I WOULD ADVISE THEM TO CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT HIM.
>> GREG, WHAT ABOUT TONE?
TERMS OF SENATOR COLLINS?
>> I HEARD TRUMP SAID THANKS JOE
AND HE SAID DON’T MENTION IT.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I TRIED TO FIND A JOKE THAT
WOULD MAKE A 4-YEAR-OLD LAUGH.
I THINK I EVEN FAILED.
THE THING THAT DRIVES ME NUTS.
WITNESS TAMPERING, IT’S ANOTHER
BLACKOUT.
THAT’S A BIG PIECE OF THIS.
>> YOU BROUGHT IT UP YESTERDAY.
>> THEY ARE MORE OBSESSED WITH
ICE CUBANS.
-- CUBES.
CHASING MELTING ICE AND NOT
THIS.
I AM INTERESTED IN GRASSLEY’S
LETTER DEMANDING THE
CORRESPONDENCE WITH KATZ.
AND THE BAR ASSOCIATION, I FIND
IT WEIRD HOW EVERYBODY IS SILENT
NOW ABOUT AVANATI.
I THINK THAT EVEN THE DEMOCRATS
ARE REALIZING HE PLAYED A GREAT
ROLE IN DESTROYING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IF HE NEVER ENTERED THE PICTURE
YOU WOULD JUST HAVE FORD AND NOT
THIS CRAZY GANG RAPE STORY.
I THINK AVANATI IS A REPUBLICAN
PLANT.
>> I THINK YOU ARE 100% RIGHT.
THE STORY WAS DEMOCRATS WERE
SAYING WHAT IS HE DOING?
>> GUYS, THIS IS NOT OVER.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR THE
MID-TERMS?
PEOPLE ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE --
THE REPUBLICAN SIDE THEY WERE
MOTIVATED WHEN IT LOOKED LIKE HE
WOULD NOT GET THROUGH.
ARE THEY STILL MOTIVATED?
>> ARE LOSERS MORE MOTIVATED
BECAUSE THEY ARE ANGRY?
>> 32 DAYS FROM NOW -- FIRST,
MANY STATES ARE VOTING.
9ITATES.
OO 9 STATES.
EARLY VOTED ALREADY STARTED --
PEOPLE ARE TURNING IN THEIR
BALLOTS.
THIS WILL IMPACT THE MID-TERMS.
PEOPLE WILL BE GALVANIZED ON THE
LEFT AND THE RIGHT.
THEY WILL DECIDE THIS ISSUE IS
THE THAT GALVANIZED THEM TO
VOTE.
>> CHUCK SCHUMER THIS MORNING.
TALKING ABOUT THE KAVANAUGH
HEARINGS COMPARED TO THE
CLARENCE THOMAS HEARINGS.
COULD WE PLAY THAT?
>> THE DAM BROKE UNDER THE
WEIGHT OF CREDIBILITY
ALLEGATIONS THAT JUDGE KAVANAUGH
COMMITTED A SEXUAL ASSAULT IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
IN 2018, THE REPUBLICAN MAJORITY
CONDUCTED A HEARING THAT MADE
THE ANITA HILL HEARINGS IN 1991
LOOK FAIR BY COMPARISON.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT,
JESSE?
>> WELL, LISTEN IT’S A HUGE
DIFFERENCE IN THAT STORY.
THE BOTTOM LINE, CHUCK LOST AND
MITCH MCCONNELL WON.
IT WAS A HUGE VICTORY FOR MITCH
McCONNELL.
JUST AS BIG FOR GRASSLEY AND FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
THINK ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
YOU HAVE A WINDOW.
TWO YEAR WINDOW.
YOU HAVE THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE AND YOU HAVE THE HOUSE.
THE AMOUNT OF STUFF THAT THIS
CONGRESS AND THIS ABOUT THE GOT
DONE IN THIS VERY SMALL WINDOW,
HISTORIC OPPORTUNITY.
WAS ENORMOUS.
YOU THINK ABOUT TWO SUPREME
COURT JUSTICES.
ISIS, AND NORTH KOREA AND TAX
CUTS AND REPEALING OBAMACARE.
>> NEW NAFTA.
>> A SWEEP OF THE AGENDA FOR THE
CONSERVATIVE CAUSE.
I THINK PEOPLE RESPECT THE FACT
THAT THIS PRESIDENT DID NOT BACK
DOWN.
THAT MITCH MCCONNELL DID NOT
BACK DOWN.
A LOT OF REPUBLICANS WOULD HAVE
GOTTEN SQUISHY IN THIS SITUATION
IN THE FACE OF THIS HYSTERICAL
DEMOCRATIC ONSLAUGHT.
THEY HUNG TOUGH AND BASED IT ON
FACTS.
I BELIEVE THEY WILL BE REWARDED
FOR THAT IN THE MID-TERMS.
>> SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM SAID
NOTHING BROUGHT THE REPUBLICANS
TOGETHER LIKE THIS HAS.
HE IS NOT PARTISAN.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHERE LINDSEY
GRAHAM IS COMING FROM.
HE IS UP SET AT THE PRESIDENT
BEING NICE TO THE NORTH KOREA
LEADER AND GOLFING WITH HIM ON
THE WEEKENDS.
THAT’S WHY HE IS SO VALUABLE NOW
OVERALL.
A COUPLE OF THINGS HAPPENED.
IN THE BEGINNING "ME TOO" AND
HARVEY WEINSTEIN.
SEXUAL ASSAULT IS SERIOUS.
BUT IT CHANGED DID HE DO IT BACK
IN HIGH SCHOOL?
WHAT HAPPENED?
ALL OF A SUDDEN PEOPLE SAID
WOMEN SHOULD GET THEIR RIGHTS
AND BE HEARD, THEY HAVE SONS,
BROTHERS, HUSBANDS AND WONDER
WHAT IF WOMEN ALSO HAVE A MALE
COUNTERPART WHO FIND THEMSELVES
IN TROUBLE?
THE THIRD THING WAS IN MY
UNOFFICIAL POLL, A LOT OF PEOPLE
DRANK IN HIGH SCHOOL AND
COLLEGE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE AGE WAS 18.
>> DID THEY THROW ICE?
>> THAT’S WHAT I AM SAYING.
THEY WENT FROM SEXUAL ASSAULT
DEAD SERIOUS TO A
DEAD SERIOUS TO I HAD A FEW
BEERS IN HIGH SCHOOL.
PEOPLE SAY NOW YOU CAN’T HAVE A
BEER IN HIGH SCHOOL OR COLLEGE.
IF SOMEONE IN THE HALLWAY
DOESN’T LIKE YOU, THEY BECOME A
STAR.
>> IT DOESN’T MATTER WHAT AGE
SEXUAL ASSAULT OCCURS.
>> IT MATTERS IF IT OCCURRED.
>> IT MATTERS THAT PEOPLE ARE
ABLE TO DESCRIBE THEIR TRAUMA
AND SPEAK THEIR TRUTH.
>> TREAT IT SERIOUSLY.
>> IT RUINS LIVES AND NOT JUST
IN TERMS OF PUBLIC REPUTATION
BUT IN TERMS OF PEOPLE’S ABILITY
TO LIVE THEIR TRUTH.
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND SEXUAL
HARASSMENT ARE BOTH CRIMES.
THEY WERE NOT RECOGNIZED AS A
CRIME 5 DECADES AGO?
>> SEXUAL ASSAULT?
>> SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
>> OKAY, SEPARATE THEM.
>> TWO DIFFERENT THINGS AS YOU
KNOW.
ONE YEAR AGO AFTER THE "ME TOO"
MOVEMENT CAME ABOUT, NINE
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS HAD TO
RESIGN BECAUSE OF ALLEGATIONS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
THEN THERE HAS BEEN 2 WHITE
HOUSE AIDES WHO HAD TO STEP DOWN
AS A RESULT OF SPOUSOL ABUSE AND
THREE CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATES
LOST.
WE CAN’T MAKE LIGHT OF IT.
>> I DON’T THINK ANYONE IS
MAKING LIGHT OF IT.
OF THOSE PEOPLE, THEY DID IT.
THEY SHOULD RESIGN.
THEY SHOULD GET OUT.
BRETT KAVANAUGH SAID I NEVER MET
HER.
I THINK THAT SAID HAD TO BE
LISTENED TO.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> NO ONE IS TREATING THIS
LIGHTLY.
WHAT YOU ARE DOING, YOU ARE
GENERALIZING BEHAVIOR TO AN
ENTIRE GROUP.
YOU WENT THROUGH SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES.
YOU ARE GENERALIZING TO SOMEBODY
WHO IS INNOCENT.
JUST BECAUSE SOMEONE ELSE DID
SOMETHING, DOESN’T MEAN THIS
PERSON DID IT.
THAT’S CALLED PREJUDICE.
TAKING AWAY THE RIGHTS OF THE
INDIVIDUAL IS PREJUDICE.
THAT’S WHY THIS MID-TERM IS SO
IMPORTANT.
WE NEED TO TEACH THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY A LESSON THEY WILL NEVER
FORGET.
YOU DON’T F WITH OUR SYSTEM OR
WITH OUR DUE PROCESS AND YOU
DON’T LYNCH SOMEBODY BASED ON
SOME ACCUSATIONS.
>> WHEN ANITA HILL HAD TO BE
HEARD, IT WAS SIX DEMOCRATIC
WOMEN WHO MARCHED ON DEMOCRATIC
SENATORS.
IT’S NOT ABOUT PARTISANSHIP.
TO MAKE THIS A PARTISAN BATTLE.
>> I AM TALKING ABOUT AN
INDIVIDUAL.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> BECAUSE A REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT WANTED TO SEE A FAIR
INVESTIGATION.
THAT WAS GEORGE HERBERT WALKER
BUSH AND A DEMOCRATIC CHAIR SAID
INVESTIGATE THESE ALLEGATIONS.
THAT’S THE POINT I AM MAKING.
I AM NOT GENERALIZING.
SOMEONE WHO HAS KNOWN
DISCRIMINATION DO NOT LIKE
DISCRIMINATION.
>> NEITHER DO I.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> DIANNE FEINSTEIN COULD HAVE
HAD A FIRE INVESTIGATION IF SHE
TOOK CARE OF THIS IN AUGUST.
>> ACTUALLY JULY.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> THAT’S WHY YOU DO AN FBI
BACKGROUND
.
THEY RESPECT CONFIDENTIALITY?
>> WAS THE FBI’S HAND TIED?
>> THEY TALKED TO 11 ALLEGED
WITNESSES AND NO ONE SAID
ANYTHING DIFFERENT.
>> HOW DO WE KNOW?
>> HOW DARE YOU QUESTION THE
FBI?
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> SOME DEMOCRATS SAID WE HAVE
NOT SEEN THE WHOLE STORY.
WE SHOULD ASIDE AMERICANS AND
TAXPAYERS, WE PAY THEIR SALARY.
WE SHOULD SEE THE REPORT.
THAT’S ALL I AM SAYING.
>> THEN YOU TALK ABOUT PRIVACY